[Music]
last year we built a shower it was a big
upgrade for the camp but we set it up as
a quick temporary solution made with
mimosas from our land and an old broken
tarp as a drainage one year later it
worn out a bit still sort of works but
it doesn't look very nice and we're kind
of scared of what is hiding down in the
dream
so we're going to rebuild it make it
last for the coming years install a new
sink outside because for more people and
we're taking the chance to experiment
with the new material a possible
alternative to cement but still need to
figure out more about it welcome to a
new project Camp video
this is the shower and as you can see it
started to change a little bit over its
lifespan when we first installed it all
of this looked brand new the wood was
fresh but over time it started to Gray
and break down and most importantly all
this Mimosa has started to warp which
means there isn't much privacy So the
plan is to rebuild it make it more solid
make it more private rebuild the walls
and we'd like also like to add some new
details like a bench for putting your
shoes on
and then also some shelves some places
to hang your clothes so they stay dry
when it's raining
we want to replace the water catchment
basin we also want to add an outdoor
sink right now the only sink at project
Camp is in the kitchen and it can get
kind of crowded so we need a place to
wash our hands and fill up water bottles
so where are you I'm Charlie
my name is Charlie I'm 26 years old and
I grew up in Colorado I've spent the
last few years working as a builder with
a focus on creating quality affordable
housing out of natural and sustainable
materials
I like hiking camping and activities
that allow me to play outside these
activities have led to a love of
learning new things about plants animals
and ecosystems
I enjoy hitchhiking Couchsurfing and
other exchanges of kindness knowledge
and faith in people project camps focus
on bottom-up open source technology
inspires me for the same reasons but now
it's time to get some wood for the
shower
[Music]
now we have all our wooden and we've got
it measured to the lengths we need we're
gonna cut it into pieces and Emma's
gonna help me yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
because
the shower comes down
[Music]
okay
oh [ __ ] this video
[Applause]
[Music]
that's disgusting
[Music]
first we're going to install the two
posts that are up against the container
we know we've got it all measured we
know they'll be straight up and down we
know they'll be solid
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Emma what's it like to be a celebrity
it's lovely
[Music]
nice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we have something's really secure
everything's Square
it'd be really easy to build off of this
tomorrow
but people still need to shower so
we've got the old flooring we've got
some
a little bit of coverage so people can
preserve their modesty coming together
[Music]
morning two on the shower we're gonna
uncover it let it dry out a little bit
and start working again
yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
whoop
s
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
not perfectly up and down so we're gonna
put in this diagonal to correct that
before we fill in the holes and
hopefully
stays in place
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this goes up and catches the water off
the shower and then goes further up and
catches the water out of the kitchen
sink we're going to put a splice in here
so we can get some water off the new
sink
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now that we have the beginning of our
frame up we're gonna put in a basin but
before we do that we've got to learn
about concrete
this is a bag of Portland cement this is
what it looks like and when you mix it
with sand and water you get a material
that makes up most of our modern world
we mix it into mortars we make bricks
themselves out of it this is a face I
made with some leftover cement we had
took about two minutes and it will
probably outlive all of us but it's a
huge carbon emitter and as people become
more aware of how problematic cement can
be people are exploring a lot of cool
New Alternatives one of these cool New
Alternatives is this stuff called
Magnesium phosphate cement this is
magnesium oxide this is potassium
phosphate it's actually just fertilizer
we bought at a hydroponic store it's
called Mega buds so should be good stuff
and when you mix these two things
together with some water a chemical
reaction happens and they bond together
and form a solid that's a lot like rock
there's a lot of different recipes
online that ask for different
proportions of different things so it's
hard to sort through all this different
information when you approach a project
as a result probably most people
wouldn't do it so we decided to gather
it all together and do some experiments
and see how goes
[Music]
for the first test we want to figure out
the best ratio between magnesium and
phosphate and of course we need some
water in there to kick off the erection
we're going to keep that consistent the
whole time so it won't be a variable in
this
so it's only been in a minute or two and
you can see it's already
quite hard
[Music]
if I put my hand on it it's almost too
hot to touch and that's because it's an
exothermic reaction
[Music]
I'm really happy with the results a lot
of these are
quite strong most of the recipes I saw
online
suggest a one to three to one to six
ratio so I think we're going to stay
between these confines and the phosphate
is pretty expensive at least in the
forms of megabuds fertilizer
so our cheapest ratio is this one the
one to six
and it's
seems very strong
[Music]
in this experiment we're going to be
playing with the ratio between our
binder magnesium oxide and phosphate
and water and we're going to keep adding
more and more water to see how it
affects the mixes see how it affects the
curing time the ratio between the
magnesium oxide and phosphate will stay
the same the whole time and it will be
the one we chose last time
one part phosphate to six parts
magnesium oxide so we're increasing the
water every time not really sure how
it's going to affect it so let's see
what happens
this one it's really solid definitely
isn't as strong as the first one but
still pretty strong the next one up is
still very soft and spongy and the last
one something totally different happened
there's still some water floating on top
it'll be nice to have the longer working
time and the looser mixture
of the higher water percentage but we
want the strength of the lower water
percentage going forward we're going to
try and fall somewhere in the middle
between these two
in this experiment we're going to be
adding borax the reason we're doing that
is because supposedly it slows down the
reaction time as our control sample
we're going to use the same ratio that
we've used as our control in the last
one and then for the experiment we're
going to be adding
0.05 of the weight of binder in borax
just about what I saw online as the
regular amount added to is mixed like
this but we want to kind of push it a
bit see where it starts to change things
see where it starts to get weak or weird
so these have been sitting for a couple
hours and it seems like they did firm up
quite a bit we're gonna keep using the
0.15 because it doesn't seem that much
weaker and the slower curing time makes
it a lot easier to work with
[Music]
we're gonna do three different tests and
they all will have the same ratios as
before the first test will be making a
brick and we're going to add
sand and this chopped up fiber
[Music]
[Music]
in this next test we're going to use
this bow as a form
and take burlap and run it through the
mixture and then lay it over this bowl
[Music]
well these first two are curing we're
going to do the last text to mix up a
whole lot of this material
and run these long pieces of burlap
through it
[Music]
hang them on here one after another in a
row so they kind of laminate together
[Music]
now let's do some strength tests
foreign
it started to break
a little bit at the bottom I think the
fibers are doing a really good job of
holding it together
I still like can't move it at all
I'm very impressed with how strong that
was just for reference this is a piece
of a cinder block we have if I tap it
it breaks just as easy here's the second
one it's super strong as well
now we're going to see if it's
watertight and it seems to be holding
water really well so this one turned out
really well it's super solid it looks
thick here but that's just because the
edges are kind of curled in in the
center it's probably only about a half
centimeter thick they're super strong
yeah it's got a little give but it's
mostly holding my weight there
[Music]
so there's a whole lot of research we
did going into this that you're not
going to see in this video and if you
want to learn more go to the research
module and I'll share a lot of links and
I'll share some of my tables from my
experiments all in all this seems like a
really cool material I could
see it being applied in all sorts of
different settings now that we've done
all these tests I feel really confident
putting it against the water catchment
basin for the shower
[Music]
now that we know a little bit about
magnesium based cements we're going to
take all this stuff and make the water
catchment basin
it's going to be the same ratios as
before we're going to kind of figure out
as we go the best method to install
larger scale thing
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and if there's any leftover actually
just dump it over here and I'm gonna
spread it out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that I can see
so we're just gonna mix up a batch of it
and not put any burlap in it and just
dump it all down here and spread it
around and try and make it smooth and
it's just sort of a last
waterproof layer to kind of smooth it
all out
lovely
[Music]
this is really stinky I don't like it no
it goes away
yeah yeah I've got the stuff that I have
doesn't smell anymore
[Music]
first time
so this is the Basin after
setting up overnight it seems very solid
very waterproof because the the reaction
time was so fast it was kind of chaotic
to install it but I'm actually really
happy with the result shows the
potential of the material
so something learned
are you filming
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we Salvage these boards from the old
shower and we're gonna sand them a
little bit clean them up and use them
again in the new shower
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is still a little bit wobbly
so I'm gonna throw in another little
Beam at a 45 degree angle in this corner
[Music]
[Applause]
definitely a lot stiffer
[Music]
now that we have the shelves in the
inside is done and it's time to install
the mirror the tap the shelf and then
connect all the piping and then we're
done
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this works pretty well
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
who is this
[Applause]
so the shower is done and I want to show
you a couple improvements and features
the planks are all a lot closer together
and there's a lot more privacy
the frame is all made out of cedar
but the planks are made of pine and a
mix of various other Woods that came
from the lumber yard we finished it in
linseed oil and put a multiple coats on
but it would be interesting to see how
well it lasts over time with so much
water from the shower we have this floor
panel that can be removed
so you can clean the drain and the part
that I'm most excited about
this new Basin that's been getting
showered over for a couple days and
seems to be draining and Performing well
we have a shelf for soap
and some hooks
tank soap we have another shelf for
clothes
and hooks for towels
and a bench to put on her shoes we got
this sink second hand from a neighbor
and plumbed in some UV filtered drinking
water so that people can fill up their
cups and water bottles here and won't be
going into the kitchen and crowding it
up during meal cooking times we got this
mirror from a junkyard
put in a shelf
got some nice flowers
and around the whole thing we spread
some of the wood chips we got from our
mimosa trees
and the goal of that is just to keep it
a little less muddy
make it a little cleaner for our freshly
showered feet and now Camp is an
upgraded shower I hope people enjoy it
see ya
[Music]
so now we can enjoy our new shower live
in the base camp is a little bit more
affordable and we started exploring more
sustainable alternatives to cement let's
see how this goes in the future still a
whole world to discover join the
discussion and research module to find
the tutorial and detailed information
about all the experiments we also keep
some updates there if you want to follow
it and in the next video we'll be
working in the Rune putting up the
interior walls and setting up basic
water and electricity connections so it
starts looking more like a home quite
excited about it
click subscribe and we'll see you again
next week thanks for watching
hey if you like what we do and already
want to see the next video right now you
can support us on patreon and you can
also watch them without ads